now you've previously said that the
current base restrictions could be the
worst of all worlds what do you mean by
that well just to say we we're in an
extraordinary difficult position now uh
there's no doubt that across the whole
country the uh Community transmission is
going up we're seeing hospitalizations
going up and tragically uh we're seeing
deaths uh some across all of those a
four-fold increase in the last month
alone uh and that is something that is
very worrying as we go into the real
winter temperatures drop and we're all
indoors more often yeah I think that the
you're always stuck between an
incredibly a rock and a hard place and
uh you either have to go very early and
harder than you may think and more
geographically uh disperse than you may
think or you go incrementally one week
after another or one Fortnight after
another to try and introduce the
restrictions I am in favor of going
earlier I think that when you go earlier
the restrictions can be less Draconian
and you can have a bigger impact on
transmission and critically get that r
value down to one and Below one that's
what we're got to aim for that's got to
be the objective because without that we
go into November December January and
we're going to see uh major rises in
Transmission in the community and
hospitalizations and talking to Michael
Gove he was pretty clear that he doesn't
think that National restrictions of
circuit breaker is the right thing to do
do you agree with
him I I I don't uh but you know I'm one
of the scientific advisers on Sage our
job uh is to offer that advice
politicians do need and I you know I'm
not a politician I'm not affiliated with
any party they have an extraordinary
difficult job uh they have to take
everything into account if you look at
it from I think a health and economic
perspective I don't think these are
separate I think they're very aligned I
think the best way of reducing
transmission uh and getting the country
back to where we were perhaps at the
beginning of sep September and then
making sure we have test track and
isolate working properly we have the NHS
prepared and there are things coming
along the horizon soon the I do believe
the vaccines will be available in the
first quarter of next year I do believe
that monoclonal antibodies to treat
patients and save lives will be
available in the coming months and it's
with that context that I think we need
to reduce transmission now and we need
to get ourselves back reset it at the
beginning of September as a country not
uh not in peace meal not across not in
fragments across the country but as a
whole country because transmission is
going up across the whole country it
it's worse in some parts but there is no
part of Britain now where R is not above
one and Community transmission is
increasing I'm really Keen actually to
talk to you about the progress on
treatments and on vaccines as well but
I'm just to finish on the idea of
lockdowns and restrictions um because
back in September Sage recommended a
circuit breaker if you like a kind of
short sharp National lockdown labor are
now calling for a 2 to 3 week circuit
breaker to be
introduced is it too late now for a
lockdown that would only last for a
couple of weeks no it's it's never too
late uh um in my view the best time to
do this would have been uh around the
20th of September as as Sage advised uh
that wasn't decided upon then the second
best time to do this is now uh and the
worst time to do this is is at the end
of November when uh when things will
have really uh got considerably uh worse
so it's it's it's never too late it's
better to do it now than in a month's
time and yes I believe it would have
been better to do it three or four weeks
ago at the same time though people are
pretty cynical that restrictions would
be lifted after two or three weeks
particularly if hospitalizations are uh
still going up and lockdowns come with a
real cost too uh both in terms of
people's actual lives with people
perhaps not going to AE or or getting
Hospital appointments in the way that
they would normally and also to our
health and wellbeing that's a problem
isn't it it's a there is no easy answer
here uh every choice you make has
negative consequences and and we all
need to be honest about anybody offering
you Simple Solutions without a downside
I think is doing a great public
disservice uh but if we did have the
circuit breaking out if we did take the
community transmission back to what it
was in the beginning or middle of
September that would buy us I believe
three weeks of a of a lockdown a circuit
breaker now it would buy us time to make
sure that as you say uh hospitals were
even better organized they are now and
pay huge tribute to the NHS in the role
they've played but they could be better
organized in terms of making sure that
people still had access for Cancer Care
for diabetic care for treatment of other
conditions and we could have put in
place uh I think a stronger economic
package that would support uh jobs and
livelihoods and support businesses so we
can do all of that if we just stopped
the uh overwhelming transmission that is
now going on and we'll continue to go on
one of the problems we have when we look
at the data is you're always looking at
the data in the rear viw mirror you see
what the situation was up until the 8th
of October or the 10th of October and
you have to think through what's coming
in the future not where you've been so
the on survey which is the best data I
think in the country at the moment shows
that 20 7,000 people are getting this
infection every day but that was until
about the 10th of October today it'll be
over 50,000 just as the CMO Chris witti
and Patrick bance suggested some three
weeks ago it would be at 50,000 new
cases every single day across the
country and that's almost exactly where
we are the reasonable worst case
scenario that Sage articulated three or
four weeks ago has now been broached it
is worse than the situation that Sage
advised on three or four weeks ago so
that's the scenario we're in today not a
week ago not a fortnite ago that's where
we are today a circuit break would take
us back at least a month and that would
allow us to prepare to have the
political debates which are inevitable
uh it would allow us to prepare that
economic package and it would allow us
to prepare the NHS for what could be a
very very difficult winter you're
clearly pretty worried about the
situation you know at the beginning of
the pandemic the government made a great
play of the fact that it was following
the
science as a member of sage is the
government still following the
science yeah I think it is I mean you
you you heard uh earlier this week the
the um Patrick Valance talking at number
10 you heard the Prime Minister saying
that all options remain on the table so
you know the science is part of this but
there is other elements Sage is
absolutely um aware of the fact there
are to there are many many other
considerations to take into account here
uh I think a circuit breaker would make
sense now I think it would by time
until we can get better prepared for
what will be a very difficult winter and
uh the vaccines and the treatments I
believe are coming uh within 3 to six
months I think we will start to have
vaccines and treatments available and
then the situation you're then changing
the fundamentals of this infection uh
we're not changing the fundamentals at
the moment we're trying to suppress it
we're trying to get R below one and stop
Community transmission and the
inevitable hospitalizations and deaths
but a vaccine and really good treatments
completely change the fundamentals and
then this epidemic is in a completely
different place let's talk about that
shall we uh because it it is nice to
offer a bit of Hope after all the kind
of Gloom that it feels like we're
talking to about at the minute um
there's been an awful lot of emphasis
placed on vaccines you were saying there
that you think one could be uh available
in the first quarter of next year what
exactly what time frame are we looking
at and who could benefit from those of
early
vaccines yeah on this the the the uh the
UK is in an extraordinary strong
position the the vaccine task force that
Kate Bingham chairs has done an
absolutely extraordinary job uh Britain
has access to uh a number of different
vaccines across a range of different
approaches uh vaccines come in all
different styles and and uh approaches
and Britain has uh got a portfolio
vaccines through which more than one I'm
sure will come through in uh in the
first quar
of next year I don't believe that the
whole population needs to be vaccinated
in those first few days or weeks after a
vaccine is available I think it's
important to Target those who are more
vulnerable uh and of course uh
healthcare workers on the front line of
looking after patients coming in so so I
think in the first quarter of next year
we will have vaccines we'll have more
than one vaccine it's critical as well
though that the UK and the UK has played
a really generous International role
here it's been a major supporter of SEI
for many years it's been a major
supporter of an International Coalition
called Kovac uh under the who that's
coming together to ensure it's not just
Rich world that will have access to
these vaccines but we will share them
equitably globally and that's crucial
it's crucial it's the moral thing right
thing to do it's the Equitable thing to
do it's also um the best thing to do for
us because as we can see now in Europe
this this pandemic will reverberate
around the world uh for a long time
until we change the fundamentals and we
get out of it and the only way of
changing those fundamentals is through
vaccines and treatment and the UK task
force has played an absolutely critical
role in making sure Britain will have
vaccines but also we will share those
globally and I think deserves great
great credit for that on the treatment
side yes I think in fact the treatments
may come sooner than the vaccines uh the
uh dexamethasone we know about from the
brilliant recovery trial in the UK uh
and we know now that there are coming
so-called monoc antibodies which will
attack the virus and prevent patients
getting worse and those who are already
sick I hope will reduce and save lives
there as well so you've got two
approaches here vaccines and treatment
which are three to six months away uh
we've got to get through the next three
to six months as a country in a cohesive
way and we're much better to do that
together than breaking off into Regional
North South or political divides divided
countries tend not to deal well with
epidemics uh we've known that through
throughout history uh cohesive joined up
countries that share the same agenda
that's when you make progress in public
health it's interesting isn't it because
it does feel like a lot of the
conversation has revolved around
vaccines but as you say effective
treatments could actually come earlier
if you look at the money vaccines have
been given six times more funding than
treatment do you think that actually we
should be focusing more uh on
treatments yeah we should um you're
you're right and and the vaccine you
know people see it perhaps as a Magic
Bullet vaccines are only ever part of a
broader Public Health agenda vaccines
are one of the greatest inventions
mankind has ever made but they're only
ever part of something else you need
even when we have vaccines we will still
need good testing we will see still need
some degree of isolation in those people
that are positive uh for coid and we
will definitely still need treatments
there's I can't I don't think I can name
you an infectious disease for which we
have a vaccine where we still don't need
treatments for it there will always be
people who either don't respond to the
vaccine or for some reason did not
receive it who will get sick and you
will always want to treat those so so we
will need treatments as importantly as
we will need vaccines as importantly as
we will need Public Health measures of
of uh some degree of physical distancing
for a while yet as we will need trust in
public health as we will need political
leadership these things are all part of
Public Health there's no single Magic
Bullet that will bring this pandemic to
an end but if you deploy better good
vaccines if you deploy good treatments
and you keep some degree of the public
health measures in place now this
pandemic can be turned around I believe
in the next six months maybe 12 months
at a global scale and that is changing
the fundamentals and at the moment we're
not doing anything that changes those
fundamentals you're talking about a time
frame of potentially 3 to 6 months how
is Chris going to look like for people
do you
think I think Christmas I don't think
the vaccines will be ready and be
deployed by Christmas we we will have
the data on the vaccines I hope in in
November and December and into January
next year uh Christmas I think will be
tough this year uh I don't think
Christmas is going to be the usual
celebration it is and all families
coming together I'm afraid I I wish we
could say it was uh but I think we have
to be honest and realistic to say that
we are in for 3 to six months of a very
very difficult period the temperatures
drop we all indoors more often uh we
have the other infections that come at
this time of year much better for us to
be upfront and honest now and say we're
in for a really difficult time but there
is light at the end of the tunnel there
is light at the end of the tunnel in the
first quarter of next year with the
starting of coming of vaccines and the
starting of treatments but we've got
three four five months to get through
until we get to that period and I'm
afraid yes Christmas will not feel like
a normal Christmas uh for for almost
everybody yeah thank you it's very clear
timeline that you are I know setting out
very clear and honest um just finally
this is a question that I am
consistently asking people in the
government and they never give me an
answer to it so I'm just wondering if
you might be able to shed any light and
it's about compliance because it does
feel as if you know we have these rules
and restrictions coming in but they're
only as good as the number of people who
actually follow them have you seen any
data on compliance and what does it show
yeah in fact I think compliance is
better than people think and I think
that's a really important thing to say
because actually the the real r value
this this famous R figure which I think
everybody now sort of appreciates uh the
real r value for this infection if you
do nothing is probably two and a half to
three that's what it was in February and
March of this year in this country which
is why we had such a dramatic increase
in infections in March and April uh with
the restrictions in place now R is
probably about 1 .5 so you've already
had an impact people are people are
across the country are actually
responding uh very positively to the
restrictions in my view it's just not
quite enough it's bought it's B the R
value of this infection naturally from
three to 1.5 but 1.5 still gives you an
expanding epidemic and we need to bring
that value down to one and that's why I
believe a circuit breaker is Justified
but I think the compliance across the
country is much better than people uh
appreciate and I I know there are
pictures of of bars and restaurants and
I think we have to do something to try
and encourage people uh to reduce
further but overall people are not
mixing as much as they did in January
and February they're not mixing as much
as they would normally do at this time
of year and people are still being very
cautious uh and that is why our is 1.5
not three and it also demonstrates that
with good messaging with trust in public
health and a cohesive response you can
bring our down this is not impossible we
can achieve this and we can buy
ourselves this 3 to six months until we
can change the fundamentals of this
pandemic with the vaccines and with the
treatment and then we're in a completely
different world